that cranky the veteran on the mound
what a year he has had for the astros
he has you know i mean he competes got a
fastball slider curve and change
fastball about 40 of the time slider and
curve you'll see during the game where
he he'll find out which one works better
he'll take change speed on his curveball
changeup's a big pitch for him i i see a
lot of times with lefties and makes
lefties and righties going to that pitch
with two strikes mary field here one and
two
and he does put the ball in play zach
goes for a diving attempt and correa
hustles to make the play carlos beats
mary field by less than his drive
the pitch
and he jammed him and salvi slams it
into left field for a base hit
lopez will stop at second base the
royals hottest hitter is coming up right
now in andrew benintendi breaking ball
bounced softly right side charging
altuve he fields goes to second to get
the force there the royals have them on
the corners for carlos santana
diving stop by correa gets up and he
gets santana what a play by carlos
correa to save a run
cc with a great defensive play and zach
grenke goes to greet him on the way to
the dugout
he'll battle you that's for sure lynch
knows he's got to be on his game
kind of like he was last time
second time through let's see what
happens
challenge him with a fastball
and whit goes out from second my
goodness on this road trip
he has been like a rover for the royals
like a fourth outfielder
and that was not hit very hard so lynch
has tied up altuve and brantley
and there are two down
lynch checks the runner brings the pitch
swing ground ball first picked up by
santana touches first base and that'll
do it
1-2
curve ball taps softly right side
fielded by guriel to his left takes it
to the bag himself and there's one out
o'hern goes the other way to that short
porch
jones up against the wall he didn't get
it
[Applause]
you know what i was just gonna say
three and oh take a shot to left
paul third strike zach throws him on a
fastball
and they have o'hearn in scoring
position the batter is the rookie
emmanuel rivera
line up the right field line and fair
and up into the crowd so two doubles for
the royals o'hearn comes around to score
and rivera gives the royals a
one-nothing lead in the second inning so
he was ready for the fastball
ground ball to correa three hops to
carlos makes the play to get maryfield
for the second time tonight
called third strike
correa was taking his shin guard off
oh wow
fantastic diaz
paul lean left-hander out of the
university of virginia his pitch is
slammed to left-center field but
taylor's right there to make the catch
and myers is the final out of the second
so
one out and the batter will be salvador
perez
salvi drills it to deep left field and
he gets it into the crawford boxes
so it's his 33rd home run of the year
extending his career high and for the
first time in his big league career
salvia has driven in more than 80.
that's number 81 and the royals lead
two-nothing in the third first and
second nobody out jose altuve at the top
of the order coming up now the pitch
from the lefty and a swing and a miss he
struck him out off speed with a pitch up
and that's the third strike out of the
night
another slider pulled on the ground to
wit
carlos
santana went after that ground ball so
he was way out of position lynch would
have been the cover man i don't know if
that ball was hit hard enough to be a
double player it would be first and
third with two outs for yuli guriel
there's a ball driven to left field
julie guerrielle bids for a home run
instead of bounces on the wall
one run scores brantley being held up an
rbi double for julie guriel the astros
on the board they're down two to one
50th of the game
and alvarez
thumbs one to left field and ben
attendee is there
here's the lead misdiaz
oh my
that looks like a good swing
and taylor is there tagging correa to
second base and he didn't go in with a
slide and he's going to be out
just throws off just a tad they would
have had him by a mile he's out do you
think he gets him if he slides no
down goes myers
ground ball right side and diving
stopped by guriel from his knees throws
to grinky in time
excellent play by guriel to his backhand
with the dive first pitch to ben
attendee one with the breaking ball and
it's snared on a short hop by correa to
the right of second straightens up and
throws out benetinti
maldonado still at third altuve at
second and the astros looking for a big
two-out hit from julie guriel
ball four bases will be loaded for the
big man jordan alvarez
[Applause]
on the ground and that's going to be cut
off by nikki lopez so go ahead and
circle that one on your scorecard lynch
wiggles out of a very difficult jam
nobody out bottom of the six royals lead
two to one and jake myers stands in he
is lined out and struck out
did he make contact he did not just
popped out of salvi's gloves
long pause now the 1-1 and a swing and a
grounded a third rivera has it goes to
second one on to first that's two nobody
out and the royals turn the lineup over
and that'll bring up whitmer field with
runners on basin nobody down
and the pitch is swung on and pulled
fair down the left field line by the
diving third baseman diaz it goes off
the sidewall where it juts out and rolls
over to left center field taylor comes
in to score it's an rbi double rivera
stops at third the royals lead is three
to one second and third one out for
salvador perez
on the ground to garcia the ball pops
out of his glove and the throw is high
salvi's digging for second he is going
to be safe now tuvas seemed a little
surprised by that salvi went in without
a slide
quick decision in new york there you go
jordan alvarez 25 homers 85 rbis
alvarez swings and misses and strikes
out he is stranded seven
alberto with the runner at second base
and one out
into left field that's going to be down
for a hit great break off second by
santana the throw home is going to be in
time
taylor jones guns down a runner for the
second time in this home stand
two on with two out and the rookie
rivera coming up
and rivera hits it hard and up the
middle and into center field
hanzer alberto is around third and he
will beat the throw which is cut off and
for the second time tonight rivera comes
through with two outs
and the royals are up by four now the
batter with merrifield
and he swings and drives it to left and
that's going to find the gap and roll
all the way to the wall
in comes taylor rivera right behind he
will score and the royals go in front
7-1 how about this
a triple for whitmer field
[Applause]
and there's a ground ball bobbled at
third
and then bobbled at second
and second base umpire nestor ceja says
that ben attendee is out on transfer
and carlos santana
may have injured himself as he was
running up the line
i think they're going to take carlos out
of the ball game
and the royals win it tonight 7-1 in
houston that clinches the season series
the royals have won four of five against
the astros
you